[Música]
[Aplausos]
então o brasil um dos maiores mercados
pet do mundo
a gente tem milhões de animais de
estimação ea relação que a gente cria
com eles é algo incrível todo mundo que
tem seu cachorro sabe como é que é
chegar em casa e ele você pode sair por
cinco minutos mas recebe como ninguém te
recebe o mesmo de um ano depois você
viajar
só que eu vim falar de cachorros um
pouquinho diferentes eles não são a
gente não vem falar de pet vem falar de
cão guia e com um guia é um cachorro um
pouquinho especial um pouquinho
diferente a história dele
então eles são selecionados filhotes
eles são colocados numa família traz
serem socializadas apresentados para a
sociedade para todos os ambientes é
depois ele volta 1% de treinamento para
receber o treinamento específico
aprender a usar o uniforme de trabalho
deles
ig há uma pessoa com deficiência visual
pela cidade é de cada dez cães que em
tom pra esse trabalho para esse
treinamento só três ou quatro conseguem
chegar o final ea gente hoje no brasil
tem seis milhões de pessoas com
deficiência visual 6 milhões e 500 mil
pessoas com deficiência visual e apenas
170 com as linhas
então é uma disparada é incrível
variedade incrível enorme ea gente está
lutando para mudar isso está fazendo de
tudo para que essa realidade mude é bom
mas esse é o final da história né essa
história toda voltar um pouquinho no
passado começa quando era criancinha e
eu era apaixonado por isso sempre fui e
sou louco por um cachorro pra tudo
quanto é tipo de bicho eu acordava cedo
no sábado que não tinha aula pra ver um
programa que passava na televisão sobre
vida selvagem eu queria entender o
comportamento do leão eu queria saber
qual era o comportamento da girafa o que
entender como é que aqueles animais
comunicavam eu tinha o sonho de ser um
cinegrafista da vida selvagem ea vida
vai levando a gente vai levando levando
quando me viu estava na faculdade de
desenho industrial sempre apaixonada por
cachorros nessa época morando em
apartamento sem cachorro
e aí na faculdade um amigo da faculdade
umidade presente um cachorro era gaia
uma filha
jaqueta ea condição para esse cachorro
ficar foi que eu treinasse ele
bom eu tinha um hábito de juntar
dinheiro durante o ano todo viajar com
os amigos no final do ano este ano venha
a fazer isso uma viagem
eu peguei meu cachorro e fui concurso de
adestramento
nesse curso de adestramento eu resolvi
que ia trancar a faculdade de desenho
industrial
no último ano da faculdade e resolvi que
eu ia parar com aquilo tudo e que eu ia
virar adestrador
obviamente eu não falei pra ninguém
tranquei a faculdade que comecei a fazer
outros cursos e num desses cursos já
estava no workshop sobre o comportamento
animal e tinha uma pessoa cega com um
guia lá a professora época rosenfeld
daqui do rio de janeiro com um guia dela
o time não conseguir assistir à palestra
eu ficava olhando o tempo todo o que ele
achou que tava fazendo impressionado com
o cachorro subindo escadas descendo a
escada levando de maneira segura à época
para todos os lugares
eu quero fazer isso né eu já era um bom
administrador
eu achei que era uma oportunidade de
pegar aquele talento que eu tinha e
fazer alguma coisa que tivesse a maior
relevância na minha opinião na relação
do homem com o cão
aí vou eu procurar né tá mas como é que
você instrutor de um guia foi lá
conversar com ela estava começando com o
palestrante né o doctor dog é um
especialista um phd em comportamento
animal e ele me vendo conversar com ela
falou pra mim que se eu quisesse
internet com um dia eu tinha que
entender de comportamento e se eu
quisesse entender o comportamento eu
tinha que estudar psicologia
aí vou eu fazer psicologia
eu entro na faculdade de psicologia
focado em comportamento animal então
você imagina que todo mundo naquela
faculdade estava estava preocupada com
um entender o comportamento humano e eu
era o único que os trabalhos todos eram
relacionados ao comportamento animal
alguns professores tiveram resistência
outros abraçaram essa loucura com todo
carinho e me ajudaram a construir todo o
conhecimento que eu
usava eu fiz matérias extra-curriculares
veterinária e biologia para poder formar
o conhecimento que eu precisava pra
fazer esse trabalho porque no brasil não
tinha nenhum curso para formar
instrutores de cão guia até hoje assim é
muito incipiente não tem alguma coisa
ainda sólido acontecendo existem algumas
iniciativas mas muito iniciais
hoje eu tô falando de muito tempo atrás
do fórum de 10 12 anos atrás
não é tanto tempo assim mas há algum
tempo tão bom ou soube de um brasileiro
que estava mandando brasileiros para a
austrália para aprender a trabalhar com
guia e voltar para o brasil fazer esse
trabalho
eu não tive dúvida eu entrei em contato
mas por não falar inglês fluente por eu
num t1 é o terceiro grau completo e ele
me disse que não estava amanhecendo e
pedreiro teimoso que eu sou eu continue
ali estudando tentando tentando correndo
atrás em 2005 saia lei federal que
regulamenta a atividade de campanha no
brasil
eu olhei aquilo como uma oportunidade
liguei pra ela eu falei é teu
eu preciso da sua ajuda é aí ela começou
a sair com o cachorro dela andando na
rua e eu ia vendo que o cachorro dela
fazia pegava o cachorro que estava
treinando e fazer e fazer igual
aí nasceu meu primeiro clube nasceu
primeiro cão guia e foi adaptado
trabalho com sucesso
chamou a atenção de outras pessoas eu
consegui conversar com outros
profissionais que estavam no exterior e
voltaram para o brasil trabalhando com
um guia e fui atrás de fazer o segundo
com um guia e aí meu segundo dia foi a
zuca que foi o primeiro cão guia do
jonas que está aqui hoje com trava que
eu tenho uma grande agradecimento para
fazer porque ele foi louco o suficiente
para aceitar um cão-guia quer o segundo
com um guia treinado por um cara que
tava fazendo as coisas meio autodidata
eu acho que deu certo ele está vivo aqui
hoje
néné e mais do que isso ele aceitou o
segundo que o dia vindo de mim então
outro é bom a gente treinou agora no
instituto magros e adaptou com jonas há
pouco tempo
eles estão trabalhando juntos há menos
de um ano mas já está sendo uma história
de sucesso já tem um ano
olha só passa rápido e quando eu lembro
disso tudo tem algumas cenas que vem na
minha cabeça que empatam muito comigo
que são relacionadas mesmo a como esses
animais mudam a vida das pessoas
néné eu lembro que uma vez a gente
estava num evento na avenida paulista
num no prédio da fiesp
e aí a gente estava no hotel era na
avenida paulista mesmo mais distante mas
cinco ou seis quadras e eu fui chamado
cedo para ir lá e montar o estande
então conversei com o jonas faz jonas eu
tô indo lá vão montar o estande na hora
que estiver perto do evento eu venho
aqui temos kuhn e fui montando estande
daqui a pouco te escutando o pessoal
olha lá e vai parar vai para lá vai para
o livro alto da escada era o jonas e
açúcar
aí eu comecei falando procuro fugir
procura hoje procuro g
ele me chama de g carinhosamente ele
desceu a escada para jucá a zuca vem
andando parou na minha frente e aí todo
mundo foi exatamente o que eles fizeram
é todo foi o e naquele momento eu olhei
para ele e falei como é que se chegou
aqui e aconteceu uma coisa me dei conta
de duas coisas uma é que eu ainda estava
um certo preconceito em mim porque eu
parei pra pensar como é que o cara cego
saiu do ponto e chegou no ponto b
sozinho foi nos custos
junto a ele fazer isso ele tem que fazer
isso é isso que ele tem que fazer mas eu
me toquei como a gente fica com um
preconceito guardadinho achando que as
pessoas não são capazes né
e aí resolvi acabar com isso e a outra é
com um incrível é você ver a relação que
o cachorro cria uma pessoa e ela vai
sair do hotel
pergunta para onde fica o prédio da
fiesp e ela vai seguindo aquela
instruções virar à direita para a
esquerda e vai com segurança na avenida
paulista atravessando a rua atravessando
a avenida até chegar no prédio da fiesp
para alto da escada
ele desceu não rolou então um cachorro
para o direito né isso move a gente já
que cada vez mais aqui no brasil né e
outras histórias como essa são
emocionantes assim coisas simples no
nosso dia a dia a gente acorda a gente
levanta escolhe a roupa que quer você
está vendo a cor da camisa que você está
escolhendo você tá vendo onde estão suas
coisas e tem gente que não tem essa
possibilidade de enxergar nada disso
a dificuldade não pára aí e aí você pára
e pensa assim eu quero tomar um café
você levanta você vai para a padaria que
você gosta você perde o café que você
quer de maneira totalmente independente
e tem gente que vai fazer isso é uma
grande dificuldade e nessa história o
edu que é um outro cara que recebeu um
cão-guia nosso que abriga me ligou aqui
sempre no último dia a gente treina e aí
acaba o treinamento chega no último dia
a gente fala né agora é hora de você
ganhar o mundo
e eu falei isso e dor no dia seguinte
quando me ligou de uma padaria que
niterói é conhecida a tradicional à
beira-mar e me falou cara estou aqui
tomando café
sozinho eu vim com o meu cachorro tem
anos que eu não faço isso sozinho ea
graça esse cachorro
então é incrível como é que eles podem
mudar a vida das pessoas e esse mesmo
edu
algum tempo depois não sei se foram anos
não sei se foram mesmo sem precisar de
verdade eu estava na praia de icaraí em
um ponto de ônibus
daqui a pouco eu vejo uma pessoa andando
com o cachorro na praia ao cachorro
andando o pai vê que todo mundo na praia
quem estava correndo parou começou a
olhar para trás quem estava parado
jogando futebol parou começa a olhar
para cá e aí que eu fui ver o que era o
educa abrir andando desviando das
pessoas na calçada né e seguindo pela
praia de icaraí e as pessoas no carro
para andando e olhando passando no olho
olhando uma senhora que estava do meu
lado parou pra mim
olhou pra mim falou impressionante como
é que pode
aí eu parei olhei para ela e falei pois
ana
como é que pode a gente obrigado
é isso
[Música]
[Aplausos]